Okay, the next phase of our quiz. So, we've previously
wrote this make password hash function that takes a name and
a password and that returns a salted version of that password.
Now we need to write the next version the next function,
which is going to basically take a name and a password
as if a user entered it you know, on the login
form or something and a hash value from our database and
returns true if they match. Now, you're going to have to modify,
make password hash a little bit for this to work. See if you can figure out how.
I'll, I'll show you what the test case
should look like. You should be able to say
h equals make_pw_hash, name and password, and then
you should be able to say valid_pw spez, hunter2,
h. This should print out true if you if you, if you have a valid hash. Now,
remember, in our previous demo, to give you a little hint when I
was running make password hash with the same inputs over and over, I was
getting a different result every time. That's because we're making a new salt
every time. So see if you can work around that problem. Okay. Good luck.